Last time we ended with the following,
a puzzle or a question.
If we say that to be a person
is to be a p functioning body,
it seems as though we have to conclude
that when you're not p functioning,
you're dead. Uh, and that is your dead.
As a person who previously
we distinguished between
the death of my body and my,
my death as a person.
Let's focus on my death as a person.
If I'm not a peak function,
if I'm not paying functioning,
do we have to then say I'm dead?
Well,
that may seem to be the most
natural way to define death,
but it's not an acceptable approach
because it would follow them that when I'm
asleep, I'm dead. Well,
not during those times.
Perhaps when I'm,
when I'm dreaming while I'm asleep.
But think of the various periods during
the night in which you are in a deep,
deep dreamless sleep. You're not
thinking, you're not planning,
you're not communicating.
Let's just suppose as seems likely that
none of the p functioning is occurring
at some point during sleep.
Should we say then that you're dead?
Well,
that's clearly not the right thing to say.
So we need to revise our account of what
it is on the physicalist picture to say
that you're dead.
What is it to be dead?
It can't just be a matter
of not functioning well.
One possibility would be to say the
question is not whether you are p
functioning.
It's okay if you're not be functioning
as long as your not be functioning as
temporary, if you will,
pee function again.
If you have been p functioning in the
past and you will be p functioning again
in the future p functioning
for person functioning,
you will be p functioning again in
the future, then you're not dead.
Well that's a at least an improvement
because then we can say look while you're
asleep, even though there's
no p functioning going on,
the lack of p functioning is temporary,
so you're still alive.
But I think that won't quite do either.
Let's suppose that come Judgment Day,
God will resurrect the dead.
And let's just suppose that the correct
theory of personal identity is such as
to put aside any worries we might have
along with Vaughn in wagon that we
discussed previously. So whether or not
on resurrection day that would really be,
you are not, suppose it would be
you. So God will resurrect the day.
The dead Judgment Day comes,
the dead are resurrected
well and other p functioning.
So it turns out that during that
period in which uh, they were dead,
they were only temporarily
not be functioning.
But if death means permanent
cessation of p functioning,
then it turns out the dead
weren't really dead after all.
They were only temporarily
not p functioning,
just like we are temporarily not
p functioning when we're asleep.
Well that doesn't seem right
either on Judgment Day,
God resurrects the dead.
It's not that he simply wakes
up those in a deep, deep sleep.
So the proposal that death is a matter
of permanent cessation of p functioning
versus temporary. That doesn't seem
like it's going to do the trick.
But what else do we have up our sleeves?
Here's a different proposal that I
think is probably closer to the right
account. We might say,
look, while you're asleep,
it's true that you're not p functioning.
For example,
you're not doing your
multiplication tables,
but although you are not
engaged in p functioning,
and it does seem true to say
that you still can pee function,
you still couldn't do your
multiplication tables.
Although it's not true that
you are speaking French.
Let's suppose that you
know how to speak French.
It's still true of you while you're
asleep that you can or could speak French.
How do we know this? Well, all we have
to do is just, you know, wake you up.
We wake you up and we say, Hey
John, what's three times three?
And after you stop
swearing us, you say, well,
it's nine or we say Linda, hey, you know,
conjugate touching such a verb and French,
you can conjugate it.
Even though you were not engaged in
p functioning while you were asleep.
It's still true that
while you were asleep,
you had the ability to
engage in p functioning
abilities aren't always actualized.
European functioning is actualized
now because you're engaged in thought,
but you don't lose the ability to think
during those moments when you're not
thinking.
Suppose we say then that to be alive as
a person is to be able to engage in p
functioning
and to be dead then is to be
unable to engage in p functioning.
Why are you unable?
Well,
presumably because whatever cognitive
structures it takes in your brain to
underwrite the ability to pee function,
those cognitive structures have
been broken so they no longer work.
It's when you're, when you're
dead, you're brain is broken.
It's not just that you're
not engaged in p functioning.
You're no longer able to
engage in p functioning.
That at least seems to handle
the case of sleep properly.
Although you're not engaged in
PE functioning, you're able to,
so you're still alive.
Take the dead.
He'll be resurrected on judgment day.
Although they will be engaged
in pay functioning later on.
It's not true right now that
they can engage in p functioning.
Their bodies and brains are broken
until God fixes them so they're dead.
All right. That seems to give
the right answer and in fact,
it gives us some guidance how to
think about some other puzzling cases.
Take somebody who is in a coma,
not engaged in p functioning.
Their body, let's stipulate,
is still alive. The their,
their heart's still beating.
The lungs are still breathing
and so forth, but we wonder,
is the person still alive?
Does the person still exist?
Well,
they're not engaged in p functioning.
That's pretty clear. We want to know,
can they engage in p functioning?
Now at this point,
we'd want to know more about the
underlying mechanics about what's gone on.
In the case of the coma,
if the following is the right description,
then we perhaps it should say,
that's still alive.
Look when somebody's asleep,
we need to do something to in effect,
wake them up.
Something to turn the functioning back on.
The,
the cognitive structures are still there,
but the on off switch is switched to off.
Perhaps that's what it's like when
somebody's in a coma or perhaps at least
certain types of comas.
Of course to turn the on off switch on.
It's harder when somebody's
in a coma. It's, it's, it's,
it's a bit more as though to continue
with the metaphor of the on off switch as
though not only is the switch
turned to off, there's a,
there's a lock on the switch and so we
can't turn the switch on in the normal
way. You know, pushing the person
in Tacoma and saying, wake up,
Jimmy doesn't do the trick,
but for all of that,
although the on off switch
may be stuck in off,
if the underlying cognitive structures
of the brain are such as to still make a
chew that flipped the on switch back to
on and the person can still engage in
cognitive p functioning. Maybe the right
thing to say is the person's still alive
coma case too. I'm not sure whether this
really shouldn't be called the calm,
I don't know the
biological medical details,
but imagine that what's gone on is there
has been decay of the brain structures
that underwrite the cognitive functioning.
So now it's not just at the
on off switch is stuck in off.
The brain's no longer capable of engaged
in these higher order p functions.
This might be a persistent vegetative
state with no possibility of turning it
on.
Even in principle of such a person,
we might say there are no longer capable
of p functioning and that perhaps the
right thing to say is the
person no longer exists,
so they no longer exist as a person,
even if the body's still alive today.
So far so good.
Here's a harder case to think about.
Suppose we put somebody in a
state of suspended animation,
cool their body down so that the various
metabolic processes come to an end.
They stop now as, as I'm sure you know,
we're able with various lower organisms
to put them in a state of suspended
animation. And then the amazing thing is
if you heat them back up again properly,
they sort of start functioning again.
Now we can't do that yet with humans,
but it doesn't jump out at us,
at least at that should
be an impossibility.
So suppose we eventually learn
how to do this with humans.
And now suppose we take Larry and put
him in a state of suspended animation.
Is he dead?
Well,
most of us don't feel comfortable
saying that he's dead.
Just like we don't feel
comfortable saying that the,
let's suppose we could do this with,
with a fruit fly.
I don't know whether we can or can't.
Suppose we can because we
do it with a fruit fly.
Don't feel comfortable
saying the fruit flies dead.
Rather it's in a state of
suspended animation. Well,
similarly then perhaps we wouldn't
want to say that Larry is dead and, uh,
the broken [inaudible] account
of death allows us to say,
Larry's not dead.
The structures in the brain,
which would underwrite the ability
to engage in p functioning,
they're not destroyed
by suspended animation.
So perhaps in the relevant sense,
the person can still engage
in p functioning so they're
not dead good enough.
And the other hand,
it doesn't seem so plausible.
Doesn't seem intuitively right
to say that they're alive,
you know? Is is Larry Alive when he's
in a state of suspended animation? No.
That seems like he's not alive either.
Oh, that's a bit puzzling, right? It's,
it's as though we need.
Normally we think that, well,
either you're alive or you're dead.
The two possibilities
exhaust the possibilities.
But thinking about suspended animation
suggests that we may actually need a
third category suspended,
neither alive nor dead. Well, all right.
If, if we do introduce a
third possibility, I'm not
sure this is the right thing.
It's, it's, it's,
it's not clear what's the right or best
thing to say about suspended animation,
but at least that doesn't seem
like an unattractive possibility.
If there are three possibilities,
dead,
alive or suspended to be dead,
we can still say,
you gotta be broken,
incapable of functioning.
Suspended isn't broken,
it's just suspended.
But then what do you need to be alive
in addition to not being broken?
What do you need to be alive?
While the initially tempting thing to
say is not only are it broken but you're
actually engaged in p functioning,
but if we say that,
then we're back to saying that somebody
who's asleep isn't really alive.
That doesn't seem right either.
So we need some account to distinguish
between suspended animation and out and
out being alive and I'm not
quite sure how to draw that line,
so I'll leave that to you as a
puzzle to work on, on your own.
That puzzle aside,
it seems to me that once
we become physical lists,
there's nothing especially
deep or mysterious about death.
The body is able to function
in a variety of ways.
When some of those lower biological
functions are occurring, the body's alive.
When all goes well,
the body is also capable of
engaging in higher order,
higher order,
personal p functioning,
and then you've got a person,
the body begins to break.
You get the loss of pay functioning and
at that point you no longer exist as a
person.
When the body breaks some whore,
you get the loss of
biological or be functioning.
And then the body dies.
There's nothing especially
mysterious about death,
although there may be a
lot of details to work out.
From a scientific point of view,
what are the particular processes that
underwrite biological functioning?
What are the particular processes
that underwrite personality or person
functioning?
Still?
There are a couple of claims about death
that get made frequently enough about
death being mysterious and one way or
another that I want or special or unique
that I want to focus on in effect
from the physical point of view,
although death is unique because it sort
of comes at the end of this lifetime of
various sorts of functions,
there's nothing especially
puzzling.
Nothing especially mysterious,
nothing especially unusual
or hard to grasp about it,
but there are a handful of claims that
people make about death suggesting that
they think and they think we all think
that death is mysterious or unique or
hard to comprehend and want
to examine a couple of these.
One of them I'll get to later, not
later today. Then the next lecture.
Sometimes people say that we die
alone or everybody dies alone,
and this is something this is supposed
to express some deep insight into the
nature and uniqueness of death.
So although we're able
to eat meals together,
we're able to go on vacations
together and take classes together.
Death is something we all
have to do by ourself.
That's the claim. We all die alone.
That's a claim. I'll come back to you.
Why do I want to look to look at first
is the suggestion that somehow and some
level,
nobody really believes
they're going to die at all.
Now,
having distinguished between what we've
called the death of the body and the
death of the person, the question
whether or not you're going to die,
it needs to be distinguished.
The question whether or not you
believe you're going to die,
it needs to be distinguished,
distinguished. If somebody says, you know,
nobody really believes they're going to
die, they could mean one of two things.
They could mean nobody really believes
they're going to cease to exist as a
person. First possibility,
second possible claim.
Nobody really believes
they're the underground.
They're going to undergo
the death of their bodies.
Let's take these in turn.
Is there any good reason to believe that
we don't believe that we're going to
cease to exist as a person?
Wow.
Well,
the most common argument for this
claim I think takes the following form.
People sometimes say,
since it's impossible
to picture being dead,
it's impossible to picture being dead,
but as to say it's impossible to
picture your own being dead. You know,
each one of us has to think about this
when the first person perspective or
something like that. Think about
your dying. You're being dead.
Since that's impossible to picture.
That is impossible to imagine.
Nobody believes in the possibility
that they're going to die,
but the grinders cease to exist.
The idea seems to be that you can't
believe in possibilities that you can't
picture or imagine
now that that hypothesis,
that that thesis,
that assumption could be challenged.
I think probably we shouldn't believe
the theory of belief which says that in
order to believe in something,
you got to be able to
picture it or believe it.
Okay.
But let's grit that assumption
for the sake of argument.
Let's suppose there,
in order to believe in something,
you've got to be able to picture it.
What then?
How do we get from there to the conclusion
that I can't believe that I'm going
to die. I'm going to cease
to exist as a person. Well,
the thought of course is I can't
picture or imagine my death.
I can't picture imagine my being dead.
It's important here to draw
some distinctions. I can
certainly picture being ill,
you know, there I am on my
death bed, dying of cancer,
growing weaker and weaker.
I can perhaps even picture
the moment of my death.
I've said goodbye to
my family and friends.
I sort of the,
everything's growing grayer and dimmer.
It's growing harder and harder
to, uh, to concentrate. And then,
well, and then there is no
and more. The claim, however,
is not that I can't picture being
ill or die iin the claims got a B,
I can't picture being dead.
Well, try it. Try to picture being dead.
What's it like to be dead?
Sometimes people claim it's a mystery.
We don't know what it's like to be dead
because every time we try to imagine it,
we fail.
We don't do a very good job.
Okay.
I'm inclined to think that that way of
thinking about the question is really
confused. I mean, you know,
you set yourself the goal of trying
to put yourself in this situation
imaginatively of what it's
like to be dead, you know?
So I start by trying to strip off the
parts of my conscious life that I know I
won't have when I'm dead. You
know, I won't hear anything.
I won't see anything.
I won't think anything.
And you try to imagine what it's like
to not think or feel or hear or see
and you don't do a very good job of it.
So you throw your hands up and you say,
Oh, I guess I don't know what it's
like. So it must be a mystery.
It's not a mystery at all.
Suppose I ask,
what's it like to be this cell phone?
The answer is it's not like anything.
Well, that doesn't mean there's something
that it's like to be a cell phone,
but different from being anything else.
So it's not like anything else.
It's a special way of
feeling or experiencing.
No cell phones don't have
any experience at all.
There is nothing that it's like
on the inside to be a cell phone.
Imagine that. I try to ask myself,
what's it like to be my ballpoint pen?
And I try to imagine, well first imagined
being really, really stiff cause you're,
you're not flexible. When you're a
ballpoint pen, you can't move and,
and imagine being really,
really bored because you don't have
any thoughts or interests or no,
that's completely the wrong way to go
about thinking what it's like to be a
ballpoint pen.
There's nothing that it's
like to be a ballpoint pen.
There is nothing to describe.
Nothing to imagine.
No mystery about what it's
like to be a ballpoint pen,
no mystery about what it's like to be a
cell phone will similarly then I put it
to you.
There is no mystery about
what it's like to be dead.
It isn't like anything where I don't mean,
oh,
it's like something but different
from everything else. I mean,
there is nothing there to
describe when you're dead.
There's nothing happening on
the inside to be imagined.
Well,
should we conclude therefore,
given that we've got the premise,
if you can't picture it or imagine it,
then you can't believe in it.
Since I've just said, look,
you can't imagine being dead,
but that's not due to any
failure of imagination.
I because there's nothing there to imagine
or picture still granted the premise.
If you can't picture it or imagine it,
you can't believe in it.
Shouldn't we conclude therefore that you
can't believe you're going to be dead?
No,
we shouldn't conclude that
after all.
Not only is it true that you can't picture
from the inside what it's like to be
dead.
You can't picture from the inside what
it's like to be in dreamless sleep.
There is nothing that it's
like Ted be in dreamless sleep.
When you're in dreamless sleep, you're
not imagining or experiencing anything.
Similarly,
it's not possible to picture or imagine
what it's like to have fainted and be
completely unconscious with
nothing happening cognitively
is nothing to picture or imagine.
Well, should we conclude therefore,
so nobody really believes that
they're ever in dreamless sleep?
Well, that would be silly. Of course,
you believe that at times
you're in dreamless sleep.
Should we say if somebody who's fainted
or knows that they're subject to
fainting spells, they never
actually believe that they pass out?
That would be silly. Of course,
they believe they pass out
from the mirror fat that they
can't picture it from the inside.
It doesn't follow that.
Nobody believes they're ever in dreamless
sleep from the mere fact that they
can't picture from the inside what it's
like to have fainted and not yet woken
up.
It doesn't mean that nobody believes
that they ever faint from the mere fact
that you can't picture from the
inside what it's like to be dead.
It doesn't follow that.
Nobody believes they're going to die.
Yeah,
but didn't I start off by saying I was
going to grant the person who was making
this argument that nor to
believe something you've
gotta be able to picture it
and having, I just said, look, you
can't picture being dead, John.
Did I taking it back since they say you
can believe you're going to die yet you
can't picture it from the inside.
Haven't I taken back the assumption
that in order to believe it,
you've got to be able to picture it.
Not Quite.
Although I am step to go about that claim,
I am going to continue giving it to the
person who makes us argument because I'm
not so prepared to admit that
you can't picture being dead.
You can picture being dead.
All right.
You just can't picture it from the n side.
You can picture it from the outside.
I can picture being in
dreamless sleep quite easily.
I'm doing it right now.
I've got a little mental image
of my body lying in bed asleep.
Dreamless Lee.
I can picture fainting or
having fainted quite easily.
It's a picture of my body lying
on the ground unconscious.
I can picture my been dead quite easily.
It's a little mental picture
of my body in a coffin,
no functioning occurring in my body.
So even if it were true,
that belief requires picturing.
And even if it were true that you can't
picture being dead from the inside,
it wouldn't follow that.
You can't believe you're going to die.
All you have to do is picture
it from the outside. We're done.
So I conclude,
of course you can and do
believe you're going to die.
But at this point,
the person making the argument has a
possible response and it's a quite common
response. He says, look, I
try to picture in the world,
admittedly from the outside,
I try to picture the world
in which I don't exist.
I'm no longer conscious.
I'm no longer a person,
no longer experiencing anything. I
try to picture that world. I picture,
for example,
see my funeral.
And yet when I try to do that,
I'm observing it.
I'm watching the funeral,
I'm seeing a funeral.
Consequently, I'm thinking,
so I haven't really imagined a
world in which I no longer exist.
A world in which I'm dead,
a world in which I am incapable
of thought and observation.
I've smuggled myself back in
as the observer of the funeral.
Every time I try to
picture myself being dead,
I smuggle myself back in conscious,
hence existing as a person,
hence not dead as a person,
maybe my body,
I'm imagining my body dead,
but I'm not imagining myself,
the person dead
from which it follows.
The argument goes that I don't really
believe I'll ever be dead because when I
tried to imagine a world in which
I'm dead, I smuggle myself back in
this argument shows up in various places.
Let me mention,
let me quote one case of it.
Fried Fried says, this is,
I'm quoting from one of the
Walter Kauffman essays that
you'll be reading called
death.
He quotes Fried Fried says after all
one's own death is beyond imagining and
whenever we try to imagine it,
we can see that we really
survive as spectators.
Thus, the dictum could be dared in
the psychoanalytic school at bottom,
nobody believes in his own death or,
and this is the same in his unconscious.
Every one of us is convinced
of his immortality. Alright,
there's Freud basically just running the
argument. I've just sketched for you.
When you try to imagine you're being dead,
you smuggle yourself back in as a
spectator and so fried concludes at some
level. None of us really
believes we're going to die.
Want to say?
I think that argument's
a horrible argument.
How many of you believe that there are
meetings that take place without you?
Suppose you're a member of some club
and there's a meeting this afternoon and
you won't be there because
you got to be someplace else.
So you ask yourself,
do I believe that meeting's going to
take place without me first glance looked
like you do.
But here's the the Freud in argument that
shows you don't really try to imagine
and try to picture that
meeting without you. Well,
when you do picture it,
you know there's that room in the Ma.
You in your mind's eye,
that little picture of people sitting
around the table perhaps discussing the
business of your club.
Oh, I smuggled myself in.
Okay.
As a spectator.
I've
if, if, if like you, you,
I think most of us sort of picture these
things sort of up from a perspective
sort of in a corner of the room up
on the wall, sort of looking down.
We're upset kind of a fly's
perspective. Um, alright.
I've smuggled myself in as a spectator.
I'm actually in the room after all,
so I haven't really pictured the
meeting taking place without me.
So I guess I don't really believe that
meeting's going to take place without me.
Yeah.
If Freud's argument for death,
that is to say none of us believe
we're going to die was any good.
The argument that none of us believe
meetings ever take place without us would
have to work as well.
But that's silly.
It's clear that we all do believe in
the possibility indeed more than mere
possibility. The actuality of
meetings that occur without us,
even though when I imagined meeting,
I'm in some sense smuggling
myself then as an observer
from which I think it follows that the
mere fact that I smuggled myself in as an
observer doesn't need that.
I don't really believe in the possibility
that I'm observing in my mind's eye.
I can believe in the existence
of a meeting that takes place.
Even though I smuggle myself in as an
observer, when I picture that meeting,
I can believe in the possibility
of a world without me.
Even though I smuggle
myself in as an observer.
When I picture that world without me
Freud's mistaken, it's
although I'm picking on fried,
it's not only Freud that,
uh, uh, runs this sort of argument.
One comes across it periodically
within the last year,
a member of our law school here put
forward this very argument and said he
thought it was a good one.
So people think the arguments are good.
One strikes me as it's gotta be a bad one.
The confusion,
the mistake I think people are
making when they make this argument,
the mistake I think
they're making is this.
It's one thing to ask yourself
what's the content of the picture?
It's another thing to ask when you
look at the picture, are you existing?
Are you looking at the picture
from a certain point of view?
Suppose I hold up a photograph
of a beach with nobody on it.
All right? Am I in that beach
as pictured in that photograph?
Of course not.
But
as I look at it,
whether in reality or in my mind's eye,
I'm looking at it from our
perspective as I think about it,
I'm
viewing the beach from a point of view,
which may well be on the beach if
somebody draws a painting of a beach.
But for all that, that doesn't mean
that within the picture of the beach,
I'm in the beach.
Looking at a picture doesn't
mean you're in the picture.
Viewing the meeting from a point of
view doesn't mean you're in the meeting.
Viewing the world without you from a
point of view doesn't mean you're in the
world.
So although of course it's true.
When I imagine these various
possibilities without me,
I'm thinking about them.
I'm observing them and I'm observing
them from a particular perspective,
from a particular standpoint,
for all that I'm not in the
picture that I'm thinking about.
So I think the Freud he in
argument just fails. Now.
Maybe there's some other reason to believe
the claim that nobody believes they
will cease to exist,
but if there is another
argument for that claim,
I'm eager to hear it because this
argument at any rate seems to me to be
unsuccessful.
Now at the start I distinguished two
claims people might have in mind when they
say nobody believes they're going to die.
First possibility was the claim was
nobody believes that they'll ever cease to
exist as a person and
I've just explained why,
at least the most familiar argument
for that claim I think doesn't work.
The second possible
interpretation was this.
Nobody believes their
body is going to die.
That is the more familiar humdrum
event of death where your body sees his
functioning and you know you end up having
a corpus of gets buried and so forth.
Sometimes it's suggested that
nobody believes that either.
Of course, often I think people
run together. These two questions.
When they say you don't
believe you're going to die,
do you mean you don't believe your body's
gonna die or you don't believe you're
going to cease to exist as a person?
Maybe it when people make the claim,
it's not clear which of these
things they've got in mind,
but let's at least try to not focus on
the second question. Could it be true?
Is there any good reason to believe it
is true that nobody believes they're
going to undergo bodily death?
Now,
you know after all, even
if you believe that, well,
you know your soul will go to heaven,
so you won't cease to exist as a person,
you might still believe
that your body will die.
Most of us presumably do
believe our bodies will die.
At least that's how it seems to me.
So it's a bit odd to suggest as it
nonetheless does get suggested that no,
no. At some level, people don't really
believe they're going to die. Oh, wait,
point out just how odd the claim that
is because people do all sorts of
behaviors which become very,
very hard to interpret.
If they don't really believe their
bodies are going to die. People,
for example,
take out life insurance so that,
well,
here's what seems to be the explanation.
They believe that there's a decent chance
that they will die within a certain
period of time.
And so if that happens,
they want their children and
family members to be cared for.
If you didn't really believe you are going
to die, that is undergo bodily death.
Why would you take out life insurance?
People write wills.
Here's what you should do
with my estate after I die.
If you didn't really believe
that your body was going to die,
why would you ever bother writing a will?
Since many people write wills,
many people take out life insurance.
It seems as though the natural
thing to suggest is that many,
or at least perhaps most, at least many
people believe they're going to die.
Why would we think otherwise?
Well,
the reason for thinking otherwise,
the reason for not being utterly
dismissive of this suggestion is that when
people get ill,
terminally ill and often seems
to take them by surprise.
So I've been having
you read total stories,
novella the death of Ivan Illich.
Ivan Illich falls. He
hurts himself. Uh, he, the,
the injury doesn't get better. He gets
worse and worse. Eventually it kills him.
The astonishing thing is that I,
even Ilitch is shocked to discover
that he's mortal and of course,
what,
what Tolstoy is trying to,
to convince us of what he's trying to
argue by illustrating the clean I take it
to toll stories making is that most of
us are actually in Ivan Ilitches boat.
We give lip service to the
claim that we're going to die,
but at some level we
don't really believe it.
And notice again, just to, you
know, to emphasize the point,
the relevant lack of belief here has
to do with the death of the body. It,
that's the thing that Ivan Illich just
skeptical about. Is his body going to die?
Is he moral in that sense?
This is what, uh, what,
what, what takes him back to discover
that he's mortal for all we know,
Ivan Illich still believes in souls,
believes he's going to go
to heaven and so forth.
So it's not his death as a
person that he's puzzled by.
He made,
I think he's going to die as a person.
It's his bodily death that surprises him,
his bodily mortality that surprises him.
Tolstoy draws a highly realistic and
believable portrait of somebody who is
surprised to discover that
he's mortal as he puts it.
It was a famous syllogism that people
learn in their logic classes from,
you know, from Aristotle.
All men are mortal,
Socrates is a man.
So Socrates is mortal.
Ivan Illich says, yes, yes, I knew that,
but what did that have to do with me?
Well,
it may be a kind of irrationality
and maybe a kind of failure to,
to conduct the logic,
but we're not asking is it rational or
irrational to not believe that your body
is going to die?
We're simply asking,
noting the fact that there do seem to
be cases where people are surprised to
discover that are mortal.
Now, for all that,
notice,
I presumed that Ivan Ilitch had a
will and for all I know Ivan Illich,
Chad life insurance.
So we're in the peculiar
situation where on the one hand,
some of Ivan Ilitch's behaviors
indicate that he believed he was mortal,
that his body was going to die,
and yet the shock and surprise that faces
that he overcomes him when he actually
has to face his mortality strongly
suggests that he's reporting correctly.
He didn't believe he was going to die.
How could that be?
There's a kind of puzzle there as to
even if before we moved to the question,
how widespread are cases like this?
There's a puzzle as to how are
we even to understand this case.
We need to distinguish perhaps between
what he consciously believes and what he
unconsciously believes. Maybe at the
conscious level he believed he was mortal,
but at the unconscious level he believed
he was immortal or maybe we need to
distinguish between those things he gives
a kind of lip service to versus those
things.
He truly and fundamentally believes.
Maybe he gives lip service to
the claim that he was mortal.
If you had asked them, I get more
early, what is that? Oh, of course I am.
And he buys life insurance accordingly.
But does he thoroughly and truly and
fundamentally believe he's mortal?
Perhaps not.
We need some such distinction if we're
going to make sense of Ivan Elledge.
Well, let's suppose we've done
it. Still have to ask not,
are there ever cases of people who
don't believe they're going to die,
but rather is there any good
reason to think that we're all,
or most of us are in that situation,
are in that,
in that state of belief,
where although we give lip service
to the claim that we're going to die,
is there any good reason to believe that
fundamentally we don't actually believe
it? That's the question we
have to turn to next time.